let's talk about joss
[Music]
[ __ ]
so here we are again
i almost feel like i could compile the
videos i've made about problematic
creators in general jk rowling in
specific
gareth roberts and now joss whedon and
called the whole thing
well here we are again because let's be
very honest this is going to keep
happening
probably into the foreseeable future
but i'll come back to that so
joss whedon
stuff has come out about him in specific
uh and he's kind of been in not too many
people's good graces lately anyways i'll
give some context on that in a minute
but some specifics came out uh that
really speaking personally
is kind of the straw that broke the
camel's back
i've been drifting away from whedon's
work
which has meant a lot to me in the past
i've been drifting away from it over
time so honestly it's a little bit less
like
the shoe dropped than the shoe has been
falling in slow motion
for a couple of years and it has finally
impacted the ground
so context
let's start with what has gone on up to
this point
because i did say straw that broke the
camel's back which would imply that
stuff had been going on or at least been
in
you know in the mix prior to this
so i think in a lot of ways
and some people might be able to point
to earlier stuff but i think for
most of us the first red flag
was following his divorce when
his ex-wife made some statements
that really brought into question the
image that whedon had built for himself
um and made some without
doing without being specific and without
naming names made some very unpleasant
uh inferences about how he treats
um the people underneath him more
recently
uh ray fisher who had portrayed cyborg
in the justice league film he made some
accusations
in regards to the work environment that
whedon fostered when he came in to take
over the shoot from zack snyder
and it yeah
it wasn't pleasant in terms of how he
treated other people and just
fostered a very hostile working
environment
ray fisher spoke out about that there
was a it might even be still ongoing
formal investigation at warner brothers
about that a ray fisher is now no longer
involved in the justice league movies
uh and most likely is not involved
because he spoke
out about that and wasn't prepared to
retract his statements
so that had happened
and the thing is up to this point
i think a fair number of us if not
making flat out excuses
were softening things
in our minds um at least to some degree
because you know the first thing is like
it's his ex-wife you know
most breakups aren't pleasant
and then with what happened on the
justice league there was already a lot
of controversy
uh around that it's questionable like
how
nice it would have been for him to even
come in and work on it was he getting
resistance from the people who
saw what he was changing in terms of it
not being what snyder had wanted
who knows and i'm not saying that any of
that was
likely i'm saying those were the kinds
of things that i think a fair number of
us
were at least muddying the waters with
but now charisma carpenter who played
cordelia chase in buffy the vampire
slayer and angel
has spoken out and made a statement
and i am not going to read it in its
entirety
i would encourage you to do so i've
linked to it
down in the description i am however
going to
summarize and a lot of what she says
for anyone who's been paying attention
to
um buffy for a while
a lot of us kind of suspected this
charisma carpenter describes
a toxic
harassing work environment
just in general and in specific
she cites joss's reaction to
her becoming pregnant during the filming
of the fourth season of angel
and him asking her questions
like are you going to keep it
which is an atrocious thing to ask
a woman who is not your partner and you
have no business asking her anything
about what she plans to do
he would call her fat
while she was four months pregnant and
she was
uh removed and written out of the show
effectively fired
shortly after she gave birth in real
life
now as i said a lot of us had kind of
suspected a bunch of this because
it was a known factor that charisma
carpenter's pregnancy wasn't planned
they had to do a lot of rewrites for the
season to accommodate for it and she did
more or less leave the show barring one
later appearance
after that but nothing had ever really
been confirmed and in fact some of the
statements she'd made
would seem to indicate well maybe it
wasn't all that
which is something she address
understatement and is the one part i am
actually going to read
despite the harassment part of me still
sought his validation
i made excuses for his behavior and
repressed my own pain
i have even stated publicly at
conventions that i'd work with him again
only recently after years of therapy and
a wake-up call from the time's up
movement do i understand the
complexities
of this demoralized thinking it is
impossible to understand the psyche
without enduring the abuse our society
and industry vilified the victims and
glorified the abusers
for their accomplishments the onus is on
the abused
with an expectation to accept and adapt
to be employable
no accountability on the transgressor
who sails on unscathed
unrepentant remorseless and
i need to stress that this statement in
addition to the things i've already laid
out does not exist in isolation
amber benson who portrayed tara
on buffy has not released uh as detailed
a statement but has
verified that the work environment was
toxic
and there was also something said by
james marsters who played spike
about the middle of last year
he was on a podcast michael rosenbaum's
podcast
and he talked about an incident where
joss got very frustrated this was uh
back in season two above feet when spike
was first introduced
joss was very frustrated how well the
character was being received
because he hadn't wanted another
long-term
you know people think he's hot vampire
he didn't want that his plan was to
always kill spike and he
pushed marsters against the wall and
said i don't care how popular
you are you're dead and marsters made
clear
in that interview that he wasn't this
wasn't a joking around
jovial thing oh this isn't what i wanted
oh well
that he was taking out his anger on the
actor
now there's a phrase that i want people
to keep in mind because i suspect
some of you if not prepared to express
the thought have at least had the
thought
well aren't some of these situations in
which
frustration from whedon would be
understandable
if he had a whole season planned out and
one of the actors got pregnant and he
couldn't do the season anyway
the way he wanted wouldn't that
justifiably
make him angry if things got sent off
the rails because a character was
popular in a way he hadn't planned
wouldn't that do the thing when he was
brought on to justice league to work on
a film that he had a
weird sort of relationship with and
couldn't truly do his own thing with
wouldn't that be frustrating yes yes to
all of that but here's what i want you
to remember
you can't help your gut emotional
reaction you can't help
your first thought he couldn't help
the fact that he felt anger what he can
help with you can help what everyone
has the capability of helping is how
they respond and react to that thought
the fact that he felt anger you know
what
i probably would have too but the fact
that he took it out
on the actors and made a hostile work
environment
where people dreaded speaking out
about how he was treating them because
they knew that it would make them
unemployable as actors this is not a
case of
he got news got angry shouted for three
seconds then went okay
calm down and sarah michelle gellar
also issued a very short statement she
didn't add any um new information
she didn't tell her own story in fact
indicated that she didn't intend to
however
she also made it clear that she is
distancing herself from joss and is
standing with
the abused so where does this leave us
because this is a bit different
from the other times that i have
discussed problematic
creators because
when i did that video i
very deliberately chose to focus
on people who had
what i described as deplorable beliefs
and i touched on but did not dwell on
those who commit deplorable
actions i believe what i said at the
time was something to the effect of look
if somebody does a thing
and that's largely going to depend on
your own personal ick
factor and what it takes to sort of
set you off and make you go uh
as opposed to someone's beliefs which
was what i wanted to tackle in that
video
this is kind of a bit of a middle ground
here because
this is largely about whedon's actions
things he did as opposed to things that
he
actively believes so far as we know i
mean aside from the fact that he seemed
to believe
it was okay for him to do this that's
not what i'm talking about though
but at the same time it does bear some
resemblance to
the issues i brought up in that video in
that this has clearly been an ongoing
thing this isn't something that just
happened
once we are getting stories now
from earlier in his career with buffy
the vampire slayer
early into buffy the vampire slayer
we're getting stories from
season two of that show and then
we are having other people come out and
speak
and everyone is lining up the stories
match
they are consistent and then we look at
ray fisher
and the behavior that he described
is 100 consistent so while this is a
case of
actions they have by all indications
been ongoing
he never got better
because he didn't have to charisma
carpenter actually said in her statement
that
the reason she was finally speaking out
was because of ray fisher and she wanted
to stand beside him
and explain that he was not alone in the
abuse that he
suffered at the hands of jaws
and this thing that she said that
the abusers are praised for their
accomplishments is absolutely correct
because he was successful
because he had initially successful tv
show
and then multiple successful tv shows
and then a successful film career
because he continued to make money
then he was never going to answer for
these things
why would the studios or
whoever move against him
he's making the money
there's a phrase that i think you know
we're all taught
uh or at least we pick up the squeaky
wheel gets the grease
the idea being that if you talk up about
a problem
it will be addressed
oftentimes the reality is the squeaky
wheel is the wheel that gets replaced
you bring up the problem and you are at
fault
for saying that something's wrong
the fault lies not with who caused the
problem the fault lies
with the person who pointed it out
because they removed the inability
for the people who write the paychecks
to ignore it
the minute somebody says it they have to
deal with it and they would much
rather punish the person who spoke out
than punish the person who caused the
issue and it's not even a question
of whether or not it is credible
that's never the issue it is always a
financial calculus
is it worse for us
to get rid of is it worse for us
financially
to get rid of the person making waves
or the person who they are accusing
and they nearly always will get rid of
the squeaky wheel the thing to remember
at this point is we are not dealing with
an isolated incident we are dealing with
a pattern of behavior a pattern that has
been supported and
backed up and validated by multiple
people
from multiple settings over multiple
years
and all the stories line up so unless
you're going to try and spin
some elaborate conspiracy narrative and
please don't
i'm asking you politely to please not
then we have to grapple
with a new name on the
is it still okay to enjoy their work
pile and as i've said before the only
person who can answer that question as
to whether or not
you can comfortably take in
whedon's previous work is you
you're the only one who can answer that
i can't answer that for you
because you are gonna have to decide for
yourself
how much am i able to reclaim
these works for me
so that it doesn't feel tainted by him
i found myself in a very ultimately very
similar situation
with how i felt about jk rowling
i already own buffy and angel i own
all seasons i
don't intend to get rid of those
i mean i'm wearing a buffy shirt
which i probably won't wear again for a
very long time
i don't have an interest
anymore in partaking in anything he has
had a part in that i haven't already
seen that i don't already have
my own experience of
i will not be watching
the nevers when it premieres on hbo
which
people are going to point out he's not
actually the showrunner anymore
i will point out that he created it
he was he was the director he was there
for the filming of it
it was shot over this past summer he
didn't leave the project until i think
it was november
which means that he was very heavily
involved all the way through
i was wavering back and forth on whether
or not i'd watch that one
now i definitely won't and while i don't
mean to get
uh overly indulgent in terms of
speculation
it wouldn't surprise me
if part of the reason he dropped out of
that show
was because things kind of had been
coming to a head
in terms of people talking about their
work experiences with him
and if he saw the show through to the
end he was going to have to do press
junkets
he was going to have to sit down in
front of cameras with
reporters some of whom were gonna ask
about this
it wouldn't shock me if
at least part of his leaving was to
get out of the spotlight as much as he
could i don't
know that and it's it's distinctly
possible that maybe it was just creative
differences or
honestly maybe hbo
asked him to leave maybe they saw the
flood coming and said we want your name
off this please
and he agreed to that or who knows
official word is creative differences
but regardless i don't intend to watch
that
i also personally will not be discussing
any of whedon's work in future on this
show
i don't think i'm going to unlist
the videos i already have up which isn't
much
it was a couple of lists for buffy and
angel
respectively but i don't plan to
tackle anything new along those lines
but i'm not going to judge people who
still want to talk about this stuff it
is my hope
that anyone who does
will not ignore and make excuses
for what we are learning that they will
acknowledge it and if they wish to
engage with the work
in a way that is not a conversation
about
the person who created it i hope that
they will at least
acknowledge that that is what they're
doing instead of just burying their
heads in
the sand and pretending that nothing
happened
because bearing your head in the sand
and pretending that nothing happened
is the kind of behavior that has enabled
him to get away with behaving like this
for decades and as i said at the start
we're going to keep seeing this
because the system is designed to
protect the people who make
the money it disincentivizes anyone who
answers to them
from ever speaking up because they know
that they
are not worth as much money
so it's not in their interest to speak
up
that's the consistent pattern
we end up when somebody finally is able
to break surface we end up with
other people coming out saying i'm sorry
i didn't say anything before
and i don't blame them for not saying
anything before the system's rigged
against them
and it is set up to enable
people to keep doing whatever they think
they can get away with
as long as they're profitable so if i
could have a
a total left-wing sjw moment for a hot
second
it's funny to me that the uh
right-wing media is always so fond of
talking about the liberal bastion
that is hollywood when
a lot of the rot at the heart of
hollywood in terms of the horrible
things that people at the top do is
enabled by the exact same capitalistic
system
that enables it to happen anywhere else
if you're in power and or make money for
the people who are in power
you get a pass for a while
you get a pass for long enough that you
can keep hurting people
and that's not a hollywood issue that's
a capitalism issue
but i i think i've uh shown my colors
enough
on that note
jaw sweden
another name on the pile
hopefully last time i'll be talking
about him
but we'll see i don't plan to like keep
up to date
um the only reason i made this is
because that this became
the line in the sand for me where i just
i can't anymore
and when i hit that point i usually it
usually means i have something i need to
say
but i don't have any interest
in engaging in an ongoing morbid
uh watching of whatever else comes out
i'll keep tabs on it but i'm not going
to keep talking about it
unless something happens that changes my
position i've said my piece
what are your thoughts or feelings on
this please keep them respectful
and please do your best to avoid
personal attacks especially
against the people who were abused i
will
block people off my comments very
very quickly for that
but as long as you can keep that under
control drop something down the comments
and let's talk about it
there's also all the usual stuff social
media links
down below links to um charisma
carpenter's statement as i said if you
wish to read the whole thing but you
also don't have to
i'm not going to tell you what to do i'm
not that controlling
because you are the council and i only
run the meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
now
[Music]